well this is a big rally that President
Putin is holding in Moscow he's just had
a meeting with the Chinese foreign
minister this morning dear friends
[Applause]
meetings
for the eve of the day of the defender
of the motherland in these words which
is something powerful huge I would say
something mystical and sacred
one of the prayers
with our father our father and this is
something that is close to every person
we say
motherland as well we talk about family
we talk about something big
and something that is also close to the
heart of every person
generally speaking motherland and family
within our heart is the same thing
we have Fearless people with hot people
to the left to the right there are
people
who
making this decision for themselves to
defend the most sacred the most dear
that we have the dearest thing is
today we're here to celebrate but I've
just heard
[Music]
military command of our country that
right now there is a fight going on or
now a historical
our people
foreign
[Applause]
he's a medical workers who are helping
our soldiers to come back
doctors nurses
employees of the defense sector
Transportation
thank you
of our people are Defenders of the
motherland
Buck alone figure
[Applause]
the anthem of the Russian Federation
[Music]
[Applause]
that there the state anthem of the
Russian Federation the national anthem
of Russia uh as President Putin talks
about the importance of what is
happening in Ukraine his special
military operation as he calls it says
we are defending the most sacred things
we have the family and the motherland
and he said that the bravery does not
just extend to those troops on the front
they are the Defenders of the motherland
but it's also those who are supporting
them the medical workers the defense
workers and the transportation workers
as well as all of those who are at the
stadium today they are of course
gathering for a rally to celebrate the
special military operation and to
support those who are involved in it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring it on what let's bring in
our Moscow correspondent Diana magnate
Diana President Putin uh meeting various
military Top Class there before he he
re-speaks to the crowd let's just listen
in apologies Diana
hooray to the unity of the Russian
people
[Applause]
Russia
Shimmer's name
we all know that what is going on what
is happening
our Victory because our power lies in
truth Victory will be ours
glory to the Defenders of our motherland
we
we are grateful to you from the bottom
of our hearts
[Music]
let's return to diet of magnesium sorry
Diana we thought that he was going to
say a lot more but he didn't um
you could hear the chance of Russia
Russia at the end of his speech there
presume you were able to hear them
outside the stadium as well
um it's sort of unbelievable really to
hear I suppose 200 000 people you can
see those pictures better than us we
weren't accredited to go in chanting
Russia and those final words from the
guy on this stage with him Victory will
be ours which you hear over and over
again from people here Victory will be
ours but they can't Define what victory
will look like I took away from that
short speech of Vladimir Putin this idea
when he says we're defending on language
our culture our land even if he's
talking about donbass donbass is not
Russian land donbass is Ukrainian land
um and uh but that is the justification
well one of the many justifications that
sort of Vladimir Putin pulls out of his
hat really to justify this
special military operation of his that
he was protecting liberating the people
of donbass so on stage a little earlier
we had a liberator from Mario Paul if
you think about the absolute wreckage of
Mario Paul it is extraordinary to even
think that the Russians can consider
themselves as having liberated it but
that is the way it is pitched here I
spoke to Sergey Markov a couple of days
ago who's an advisor to Vladimir Putin
and he said you know the way that the
Allies bombed the cities in Germany
Dresden
Berlin and destroyed those you thought
that you were liberating them from the
Germans and that's how it's perceived
now while Russia will be perceived in
the same way in the future that is the
kind of convoluted logic that uh you
know the propagandists uh spin on what
Russia is doing in Ukraine and this for
Vladimir Putin was a way of showing that
the people are behind him uh a message
to the Troops at the front a rallying
cry for the entire nation that Russia is
in the right that they are defending
their motherland against this supposed
threat which comes from the West which
he has detailed at length
um and actually even though you can see
a lot of people already streaming out
because mostly they just tell you it's
extremely cold uh most of the people
here believe that rhetoric they believe
that language that said a lot of them
are streaming out because they've got
buses to catch buses that were laid on
from them by state companies to bring
them here
um so uh you know these kinds of very
career graft event events have happened
since Soviet times and they happen still
a way of of of presenting an image a
propaganda image that can be beamed
across state DV that people can get
behind and believe that Russia is on the
right path
um but it does feel very Hollow
okay Diana thank you very much then a
magniforce there in Moscow outside this
Stadium the luchineke stadium where
President Putin has spoken to the
assembled crowds they're 200 000 people
gathered at that stadium for this
enormous rally to celebrate their troops
the people he says who are out there
defending the most sacred thing that
Russia has the family and the motherland